i want to start with the footage i've
seen looks fantastic oh were you pleased
with it that's great
i cannot cannot wait to see the rest of
the film oh
good i'm looking forward to you seeing
it i yeah counting the days um so one of
the things about this movie is you have
um these actors coming back um and i'm
curious how do you actually write a
script with the scheduling and what
happens if certain people
say oh yeah we we can't do the movie do
you know what i mean like where's that
like the complicate i can't imagine
trying to make this script work with all
the moving pieces well you know the
first thing you do is you say like what
story do we tell about peter this time
right what is the journey for peter
parker and then you figure out who
what else you need beside tom holland to
tell that story
and then you
beg
steal and borrow
and do everything you can to make it
work for everybody because because
everything in a movie is a reflection of
what the main character is coming going
through
so
you have to have it you just make it
work and that's what being a producer is
and we were actually lucky enough to
have a magnificent line producer on this
movie who joanne who made everything
work
how much had you known since the first
movie that you were building towards the
multiverse or was this sort of figured
out after this like when did you guys
figure that out well
when we at the end of far from home
when his identity is revealed right that
is the sort of the
the critical problem that peter has so
when his identity is revealed and his
two worlds collide
that sort of opens the world up to the
multiverse
sure um obviously the venom movies have
been what we call successful i'll use
that term um so uh obviously tom loves
playing this character have you guys
already been talking about like a start
date for a third one
uh
we are in the planning stages right now
but what we're focused on is getting
everybody to come and see nowhere
oh i don't think that's going to be a
problem i don't think that's going to be
a problem i'm so happy yeah no it's
going to be the first movie since covid
began that's going to make box office
like it's not covet oh golly yeah from
your left
no it's not even a question um i i am
though curious so you bring venom in um
to the mcu at the end of venom two how
long have you guys been planning on
doing that and um i guess let me ask
that
well you know we all talk of you know
there's there's the the the wonderful
movies that that sony makes and there's
the you know with the other characters
there's the marvel universe
there's our spider-verse movies and
we're all very careful to work with each
other
in a way that is additive for everybody
how's that that was very good you could
the politician answer one-on-one oh i'm
learning to be a politician dude
right that's great i got to stop i'm
just going to say for real though it's
going to be such a monster hit that oh
thank you so much i really appreciate it
that's so nice of you oh it's not i see
what people are clicking on on collider
it's going to be a monster seriously
thank you
you